um
so we're going to continue um what we
started yesterday
and uh
what i'll talk about today
is again work with
my students
acharya
so just let's remember what we did
yesterday so um
we said that uh if i want to estimate if
i have a coin and i want to estimate the
bias of the coin the probability of
heads then i take n samples and i'll be
off by square root of n roughly i'll get
the mean plus minus square root of n i
normalize by n so i'm off by one over
square root of n
so i have n samples my error of my
estimate is about one over square root
of n and if uh and we're interested in
um
um we're interested in estimating
distributions now of a large alphabet
not alphabet of size two but alphabets
like english
that are large like half a million so
every distribution over
k symbols
and then uh we said that
the l1 distance behaves just like it did
with the binary case 1 over square root
of n except now it's like square root of
k over n
so when you look at it you see
already you see that this is bad that's
why it's in red because first of all you
see that and the number of samples has
to be at least k at least after this
outside which is very natural if the
alphabet size a million and you see less
than a million
samples definitely cannot expect to
estimate
the distribution but furthermore it goes
like down after that like one over
square root of n
so which means that if we invert it we
had this like insane
measure the sample complexity so if you
want to get to within delta then you
need something like one of the square
so uh so then we said that that's that's
a problem and so um
different groups ours and others have
been trying to address this issue
and there are three
main approaches people have taken
one that we um
discussed ti
last time was to add a structure to
assume that this distribution cannot be
any distribution but maybe
it's monotone or a model or something
like that okay so we said for example if
you um if you add the assumption that
it's monotone then the known samples you
can reduce it from k
to locate there's a small loss here
instead of square root it's um you'll
get like uh
it goes down itself a square root one of
the cube root of this number but uh
you'll get at least log instead of uh
instead of here so there's an
improvement here
um and uh
and so this so this is one approach to
say to make assumptions about the
distribution and the approach that i
want to discuss today is what we call um
out of the durable so like maybe we
modify a little bit uh what we want to
achieve maybe it's still
close to what we want but a little
weaker and then we see what we can get
so that's what we'll do
so
no assumptions we're going to look at
all possible distributions
but
we'll see what we need to to modify in
order to get some some results
so um
we'll look at our combined probability
estimation
so um
okay so that's where we are so um
every estimator every natural estimator
that you can think of will assign the
same probability to all symbols that
appear the same number of times so for
example suppose that you have a
distribution over on the first six
letters a to f
uh and let's say you took five samples
and you get c-a-c-d-a right so for
example
then a and c
both appeared hopefully you can tell the
difference this is brown
a and c both appear twice so any
reasonable estimator that you'll come up
with will give the same probability to a
into c right
this is just these are id distributions
there's no way for you to give a
different probability to c than to a
and
b e and f did not appear so whatever
probability you give them it could be
zero but it could be nonzero but
whatever it is it makes sense that
you'll give them the same probability
um
and
all natural estimators behave that way
any estimator that you can look at will
behave that way
and you can also regularly rigorously
justifiable because if you see something
like that and you give a different a
different probability to c and to e
then you can look at any permutation and
you'll be for some of them you'll be
lower some of them will be higher
probability and because the distances is
all these distances people look at are
convex then you'll be making a bigger
error in a mean max sense okay so it's
irregularly rigorously justified so we
talked last time about
insane measures and same measures so
this is if you if you do anything else
then i would say you're back to being
the insane
so okay so any any any estimator will
have this property
that it assigns the same probability to
all symbols that appear the same number
of times
okay so if that's the case then we may
as well combine the probabilities of
things that pay the same number of times
so look at the combined probability of
all symbols that appear in a given
number of times so to be a little more
precise um
we let call mu
stands for multiplicity with the number
of um times that a symbol has occurred
and n mu be the number of symbols that
appeared
new times
and then s view i'll give you an example
in a second s mu is the sum of all
probabilities that appeared
mu times so for example again
distribution over a up to f
and let's say you took four samples and
you saw adcd okay so
n0 is the number of symbols that
appeared zero times is one because it's
just um
um
b
um the second
b did not appear and one
um
it shouldn't happen yeah so i apologize
this is the distribution of abcd yeah
um so b did not appear n one the number
of symbols that appear twice is a and c
okay and two the number of symbols that
appeared uh twice is one just d okay so
it's a distribution just over abc
um
and so so these are n zero and one the
number of things that we're zero times
once twice okay and if you look at s
zero the total probability of things
that appears zero times just the
probability of b we don't know it but
it's that probability and one is the
total probability of things that
appeared once so it's pa plus pc
and n2 is going to be just pd
students
it's just the sum of the probabilities
of the things that appear twice
so um
so
so these are the uh the sum of the
probabilities now if you want to
estimate the individual probabilities
the only logical thing
that you can do as we said from the
previous slide is just divide this total
probability and this is what you're
looking for it's
it's the just the normalized probability
so
so qa so your estimator is going to be
uh if you want to assign the sample
value estimator q p is the actual
probability and q is going to be our
estimator so qa is going to be equal to
qc and that's what you want to be s1
over n1 which is s1 over 2.
and ideally you want
similarly qb is going to be
just
uh just s0 in this case and so on is s
the estimate or is s the probability s
is the s is the total probability the ps
are the total probabilities s is the the
correct value so it's p v p a plus v c
that's what you're trying to estimate
okay
and what i'm saying suppose you have
some estimate for this for f4s then the
only logical thing to do is you'll take
whatever your estimate is let's call it
hat and divide by this but this is what
you want to get this is ideally what you
want yeah but i agree
okay so um s zero is in this case is the
probability of things that you have not
seen so that is the probability of
things that you have never seen
okay all right um
so the combined probabilities are just s
zero the total probability of things you
have not seen total probability of
things you have seen once and so on and
after the probability of things that you
have seen end times
okay
and your estimator that you'll come up
with will be e
e0 estimate for zero and so on up to n
okay so um so so again you need to
estimate to to
quantify your distance between your
estimator and the two things so we just
do the same thing so if you have s 0 hat
up to s n hat you estimate of s 0 up to
s n
then
we'll look at two distances one is the
l1 distance just
add up the absolute values of the
differences and the other one is the k
divergence it's the summation of the
real things times log of s divided by s
so um
so what we're going to do is we're going
to try to estimate the the total
probabilities the summation of
probabilities of things appeared once
twice and so on and then if you want to
estimate the individual probabilities
then like we said you're going to
normalize
so um
so let's see what empirical frequency
does
so suppose you've seen a sequence of
length nine nine symbols and this is the
sequence so you have two symbols that
appear twice a
and b
so the total probability of things
appear twice is p a plus b b
and what probability will empirical
frequency assign to uh to uh things that
appear twice in this sequence so
for you have a length nine so to a it
assigns probability two over nine to uh
b the size probability two over nine so
it will say the total probability of
things that appear twice if we call
frequency frequency we'll say four over
nine
okay very much
and just reminding ourselves that n mu
is that is the number of things that
appeared new times so the total
probability that empirical frequency
will give to things that appeared mu
times is going to be to each one gives
probability mu over n
and the enemy of them in this case two
so you multiply by that
okay
so um
the question is um for example if you
want to ask how many samples
you need um to get to l1 distance of
atmos 0.1 with some high probability
then um you notice that empirical
frequency to zero it will always give
zero probability
all right so what what the probability
does empirical frequency gives to zero
uh it's going to be zero over n times
the number of elements that appears zero
times in reality maybe you don't even
know what this number is because you
don't know the alphabet but whatever it
is if you do the alphabet you multiply
by zero till you get zero okay so um so
uh so empirical frequency always gives
zero to things that appeared zero times
it's a big problem
so take your uniform distribution
so we're trying to see how many samples
you need if you uh want to estimate uh
the l1 distance between
the total probabilities to at most 0.01
probability which is at least 0.09 so um
so suppose that you have a distribution
of one up to k and suppose you took a
little less than k like 98 percent of k
okay
then s0 then there will be at least um
there'll be at least um
the probability of things you will not
see it's at least 0.2 there could be
repetitions which case it will be bigger
it will be at least 0.02 so essentially
the total probability of things you will
not see is at least zero points this is
at least two percent right i have a
distribution of size k
i take 98 k samples there'll be at least
two percent of the symbols that they
will not see maybe more the total
probability because it's uniform is at
least two percent
um so that means that if i want to
estimate
uh but the actual the actual value is uh
that that empirical frequency gives us
zero so that means your distance is
going to be at least 0.02
okay so if you want to estimate his
distance which is which is less than
0.01 you need more than 0.98 k so you
need at least that
okay
so what this shows us is that sorry
shows us that um
this measure that we have when we are
looking at estimating
not just the individual probabilities
but the sum probabilities is still
non-trivial like in this case i want to
estimate those combined probabilities to
within 0.01 i still need the linear
number of samples
okay
at least this doesn't
is that creative
yes
how is this different from directly
computing the
so the thing is this that
we're trying to make things easier for
us so we know we know from the previous
thing
that if you want to estimate the
individual probability to an l1 distance
okay we get square root of n over k
right
um sorry so square root of k of n so um
so n has to be at least linear in k
right because if
s
probabilities can be estimated with
higher without collection
right so so what we're saying now is
we're trying to make the problem a
little easier for us maybe you'll say
it's a lot easier for us maybe we can
discuss but so instead of estimating the
probabilities of individual elements so
so let's say the sequence here is uh
a a b e b c so you might give the
probability of a and the probability of
b
and then you look at the distance what
we're saying is this that for a and b
are going to give the same probabilities
anyways if you're any reasonable any
reasonable estimate so let's combine the
probabilities and see how well you do on
the combination of those probabilities
that's a little easier because maybe
within them there's
um
maybe within them there's variability
so we're making it we're just trying to
estimate the total probability and that
should be a little easier than
estimating each one of them
okay so what we're showing here is that
this doesn't trivialize the problem if
you tried empirical frequency the number
of samples you need is the same it's
still linear
then you'll get different constant but
it's still linear
so is that okay
all right
um
so um
what good touring does is um
i guess one question one could ask here
is
this is for overall distributions right
right this is for the worse
where this will be tight will be
distributions where which will generate
some things once something's twice that
would be like the worst distribution
so do we know what the worst
distribution is uh for this particular
one i'm not assuming okay so first of
all we haven't said what the um we
haven't said what the estimator is and
so on right this is for empirical
frequency
we're just saying empirical frequency
doesn't help you that much
oh i see but you could do much better
well that we'll see okay
you're drawing from the underlying
distribution
uh and based on what you draw you i mean
your s2 values are rather
so that's right that's right so it's
kind of funny so beforehand you
estimated the probability of a the
probability of b probability of c
now you're estimating the probability
what you're estimating depends on what
you have seen
if what
correct correct so for example if
if now a appeared twice and b appear
twice then s um s
two the probability of things that
appear twice is going to be the
probability of a plus the probability of
b next time you'll try there'll be other
things that appear twice you'll be
estimating something else
and our goal is to
not estimate all the individual
frequencies but just try to get these
things correct so we saw last time we
saw that if you try to estimate the
all of them that's impossible
the best that you can get is a square
root of k over n which we said because
you have
a square root it like one over square
defense so it grows like
a square of whatever distance you're
trying to estimate which is which is
large yes yeah this one also seems funny
because just what you said the more
samples you take the more likely you're
going to have different categories right
correct but
it makes it tougher that's true but what
if that is correct that i that's the
that's the direction i would like to
hear
to say that this is a tough problem but
if you try to make to say it make it
sound easier then imagine that you have
a distribution of a size k
right then if you try to estimate the
distribution itself you need to estimate
k parameters yes
right here no matter what the size of
the distribution is you'll estimate the
probability of things that appear at 0
1 up to n so you're trying to estimate
at most n plus 1 parameters that's
independent of k
the number of parameters you're trying
to estimate is independent of k the
point is that according to what we
believe in after looking at this a long
time that's the most you can do anyways
because if things things appear twice
you give them the same probability
things appear three times so there's no
reason to try and distinguish between
things that appear twice you're just
guessing
so this is what you should be looking at
and and what we see here is that even
though we're trying to estimate only n
parameters regardless of k even if k is
a trillion but our sequence length is
100 we'll try to estimate 101 parameters
0 to 100
still the number of samples you'll need
is not is is proportional to k
s 0 s 1 s 2 and so on these are all
disjoint in the sense that the a b is
enough yeah there's some they have to
actually be estimating this k parameters
why um because when you suggest i'm
thinking of case being very large i'm
not expecting the word just
sure yeah but so if n is the number of
samples we have s 0 s 1 s 2 and so on
right but some of them so since they are
disjoint the total number of nonzero
things here can be almost k
actually um
um
i would say even square root of k that's
even even even lower right because so
that's a good point
so what he's saying is um
he's saying mind you i'm thinking of k
i'm thinking of the other regime where k
is very large because i want to say you
can learn a few samples but ignoring
that he's saying that you're looking at
s0 up to sn you're saying the number of
sis that can be non-zero is at most k
but in fact it can be at most square
root of k and that's because it could
have s maybe s1 s2 and so on if s1 the
things appeared once and things that
appear twice and so on so you can have
it more square out of care of them
before you get to rk different ones
okay yeah so that's true so at most
square root of k of them will be
non-zero that is also correct
but another related question is if you
made some assumption on the
distributions you would be
much most things would appear you know
once or twice or three i wouldn't expect
you need some distribution that
favors some things quite with high quite
high so you need some really strange
power law maybe distribution to c square
root n things right square root k
sorry k squared things yeah you might
you might you might right but but
last time i was you know there was a
friendly question that says why do you
make assumptions on the distribution who
knows the distribution is monotone what
we want to do here is assume make no
assumptions on the distribution and
you're right that maybe typically you'll
see fewer uh field multiplicities
okay
um
okay
so okay so empirical frequency we see
requires a number that is proportional k
and now remember our job is to try to
get this number be located that's
all our struggle everyone's struggling
the last ten years is try to see things
that will give you the number that you
can estimate distributions with less
than
uh with fewer fewer samples definitely
fewer than linear
so um
so good touring um so
n mu remember is the number of symbols
that appeared mu times so np plus one is
the number of symbols that appeared mu
plus one times
and um and and the good touring
estimator what it does is um
for
mu number of
multiplicity is between you know zero up
to n it the probability that the sign
two things that appeared many times is
is the number of things that equal mu
plus one times
times um mu plus one over n
okay so if you want um you can think of
it
so empirical frequency will assign its
probability which is mu over n times
times n mu right mu over n to h1 and
then nu good touring it's assigned to
this one the same probability that
empirical frequency assigns to things
that appeared one more time
right so this this is this is what we
call e of mu plus one
the empirical frequency is assigned to
things that appear mu plus one mu plus
one over n times mu plus one so the
touring actually
shifts
so we'll see in a second why why this is
actually a good estimate
um
okay so um so
so we'll show in next slide that
actually if you look at the expected
value of gmu is the expected value of s
mu so as you pointed out s mu is a
random variable now at this point
and
and
the expected value of s is going to be
the same as the expected value
um okay
so um
in particular what is the probability of
the unseen mass of things that you have
not seen so empirical frequency gives it
probability which is zero
and good turing will give you the
probability that
e1 which is the n1 1 over n times n1
and
and good touring is very useful in in
natural language processing so it goes
back to church and gale i started using
it
and and i think it's
definitely one of the standard
techniques
if you i don't know if you care about
the
motivation but um
well i guess now everyone's seen the
imitation games i don't care but um um
the
the
the germans had um
um a
password book that they gave the u-boat
commanders and they were supposed to
choose passwords from this book and they
were trying to estimate the probability
that they will choose passwords from
different pages of the book and so on so
you can imagine you have a very large
number of pages you have very few
samples and try to estimate what's the
probability that this commander will
choose from the beginning of the work
the end of the book and so on
um okay so um what kind of performance
guarantee
so uh so so we'll we'll get that in a
second what kind of performance
guarantee uh can can does a good touring
give um but before that i just want to
show you uh this part
so ah that good touring is unbiased so
um okay what i'll show you is
uh so remember we're looking at um
you have an id distribution your sample
end times
the way
we have looked at it which has helped us
simplify proofs
i think significantly of what people
have done before
is uh so they've looked at actually this
exact problem uh that i have a
distribution i sample it n times but
instead what we're going to say is that
you simply pour sodium times
so this personalization is is a
technique that people have used
um and so instead of saying you sample
exactly n times you say well simple
poissonian times try to estimate the
distribution it makes the proofs a lot
easier okay but it's almost the same
because sample points on end times
you can actually prove it so it's not
like there's no hand waving you can show
that the results that are actually uh
present here will hold the same for
person non poisson it's just the proofs
is easier and the reason is because if
you sample n times then the number of
samples is going to be somewhere between
n plus square root of n and minus square
root of n so it's roughly n anyways your
estimate is almost correct
okay so uh so so when we calculate the
expectations this will come in so s mu
is the is the total probability of
things that appeared mu times we can
write its summation over all symbols of
the probability times the indicator
function
when x appeared mu times
what's the definition of s
it's a random variable so what is the
expected value of s mu we have to sum is
the expectation of this so it's the
expectation of px times
i'll say summation of the probability of
x times the
this is um this is
the only random variable times the
expectation of one at the that executed
mu times one of that the indicator
function which is just the probability
that x appeared new times
now remember we are um
uh we are sampling things uh poissonian
times and when you do that you can show
that each symbol
x will appear for sun and px times
so
i'm i have a distribution
p1 up to pk
i sample n times
so the number of samples will reports on
n and then if i look at the num at the
distribution of the number of times that
x will appear it will be plus on n times
p x as followed
so um so the probability that
that x will appear more times is just e
to the minus npx as npx to the mu
divided by mu factorial
so it's uh this summation and then um
what we can see is that we have px here
which is kind of funny so we want to
kind of combine things here so let's
multiply let's multiply here by n and
divide by mu plus one so we'll get um
so
okay so get n u plus 1 um
okay so there's there should be okay
this is correct still correct okay so
multiply by n so get npx to the mu plus
1 and then you need to divide by n so
you get 1 over n so this okay just two
steps so we could have done it by one
and then uh multi multiply here by mu
plus one and we have mu plus one so you
get here we'll get mu plus one over n
and here you'll get uh the
the probability that uh that x appeared
mu plus one times so it will be mu plus
r
okay so that's this
you wanna agree
it should be could have been written a
little better
but
so um so what we get is um the
um
mu plus one over n
times the expected value of uh of um
uh expected value of uh of n plus one so
and this is exactly the definition of
this is the expected value of g mu
so the expected value of s mu
is this is the expected value of mu plus
1 over n times n mu plus
1. so we get that the expected value of
g mu is just the expected value of our s
okay
any questions
yes just to clarify what happens
with so okay so that's one reason why
we're doing
this way so you're right that if we if
you look and so if if you're doing this
the analysis on the exact sequence
length n
then you'll get something funny that
happens at the end um in the sense that
it will always be zero right the
probability but in reality it's not a
big deal because uh if things
in reality what people do is they use
good touring for things that appeared a
few times and use empirical frequency
for things they paid uh many times right
if you if you take a hundred seconds
your n is 100 and you see things that
appear 50 times you're not going to use
uh you're trying you know the
probability is half so you'll never use
good toeing for estimating probability
that are n
okay but if you're going to do the
analysis then you need to worry about
these things and that's what makes it
more difficult right so that one of the
things that make it more difficult
there's also dependency if you take n
samples then the things appear twice
then that number depends is is not
independent depends on how many things
we have three times and so on because
summation of
those sum to n so this analysis actually
gets rid of all of this so there's no in
this case there is no n anymore for any
for any this analysis holds for any mu
even if n is 100 this analysis will hold
for mu equals a billion
okay so it is biased if without
personalization right without yes if you
don't if that's right so um if you don't
do personalization then it's biased but
this is uh this is this is correct this
is not biased and this is yet another
thing that helps us with simplified
analysis but they can prove it too
because the bias is not that big so they
can put the results
um
okay
so okay so so this is um
so we showed that the expected value of
g mu is the expected value of s view
okay
so hopefully you see that this is nice
this is the simplest proof you will ever
see right now
um even though i maybe it's i didn't
write it in the best possible sequence
um okay so um
okay
so remember
that for if you try to estimate the
whole seek the the whole set of
probabilities
then um
um then um
you need um a number which is linear in
in k right you need square root of k
over square root of r k over n
and if you even if you try to look at
the combined probabilities if you do
empirical frequency again you need a
number which is linear in k
so with good turing
what would you think it will reduce it
so you want to estimate this combined
probability to let's say 0.01
what would you hope
so
okay so um
so
estimating the original probabilities
was square root of k over n then you
made the assumption let's say of
monotone and becomes like log of k
instead of and you have n and then you
have a different power one thread
doesn't matter okay so um so now we're
combining them what would you hope for
what would you consider to be good
so i'm trying to estimate this combined
probability to some some number like one
percent what would you consider good so
empirical frequency you can do it with
linear
okay
any other bids
constant okay so yeah that would be very
good um
and indeed it is okay so it's a constant
so um so in in what i'll write here with
hyperbolic stands for probability which
is one minus one over polynomial name so
it's probably close to one
and
i'm going to hide um
holy logarithmic factors if i have n
times log n i'll just write n so i don't
care about the logarithmic
factors so uh what mcallister and
shapiro so started looking at the spawn
showed in 2000 actually
so this pump a lot of people have looked
at good touring but until 2000 they just
had like some kind of um
hand waving
arguments why why it works but there
were no proofs okay
so um
what they showed is that
the
gmu that they off by the most
are some constant there'll be some
logarithmic factors of mu plus one over
square root of n so that would be
another square log
absolutely log of log of n
um
so
so that's what they showed
so the nice thing about this is that um
it holds for all distributions
regardless of support size so we are
trying to estimate s 0 s 1 s 2 and so on
no matter what the support size is
this is off by the most this with high
probability for really close to 1.
so that means that if you give me a
number of samples of 100 i can tell you
how well i estimate this
and i don't care what the distribution
is the solution could be of an infinite
support k could be infinity
i don't care given the number n i know
what how close i am to the distribution
um
and so that's the good thing
uh it's also good when mu is small so if
mu is small then you get one over square
root of and it's nice however uh when mu
is bigger than square root of n this is
meaningless
right because again
these are probabilities that are at most
one that's fine
um so
so this therefore does remember we're
interested in looking at the l1 distance
for because we're looking at
classification applications so we look
at the l1 distance so if you want to
show that the l1 distance goes to zero
this will not give it to you
because it will give you up to you know
up to one over square root of n that's
fine we'll sum to something or maybe up
to one over n but then you need to some
things that are going to be one
okay so it doesn't give that to you so
is that clear everyone is okay
so um so the question is what happens
when mu is bigger than square root of n
and um and and broken mansur in 2005
uh what they did was they combines very
logical they combine good turing and
empirical
empirical frequency estimators let's
call it cmu and uh what they did was uh
that if mu if the number of samples is
bigger than n to the point four then
they use empirical frequency estimator
if the number of samples is less than
and to the point four then the users are
good to our estimators
and with that
they showed that the l1 distance is at
most goes at most uh
like 1 over into the 1 6 and then the
scale diverges let's not worry about
this these results are always going to
be the square of this so there's uh the
pin square is an equality that relates
um
that relates um
l1 distance and kl divergence and and
these results almost
i mean they're in in this case they
always
go the way paint's going in quality
expensive to go so
this will be roughly the square of that
um
so so the nice thing is that you can so
you can estimate the distribution to l1
distance independently of the alphabet
size
okay so that's the nice thing about that
and
so but now let's
let's just see so so let's see what it
means so for example if you um
uh if you want to estimate um
l1 to be less than uh 0.1 with
probability let's say 0.9 then you need
at least so you need roughly one million
right because um this this doesn't
matter but this l1 is going to be just
point one to the six
one of that will give you a million okay
so still there's something to
you know to be concerned about that
so if you want to estimate the
distribution
um
to within l1 distance of 10
then you need a million samples and you
may not have that much as we discussed
last time um maybe you're estimating
things in a context of two previous
words so to get a million times this
context will take you a lot a lot of
samples so there's still more to be
considered
any questions
okay so so so so then one could ask
whether this is optimal so the results
that we derived and
like i said mostly
uh data's work but also with
ashkan and jadev
so um so a few results so first of all
uh you want to you may want to ask
whether you can improve uh good touring
and uh and empirical frequency this
combination so what does this mean means
could mean that maybe you take a
different they have a cutoff
underneath for things appealed a few
times there is good touring for things
appeared more times they use the
empirical frequency the cutoff is into
the point four maybe you can vary the
cutoff or maybe what you could do is
some linear combination any kind of
combination between the two
and the answer is no uh so um
no matter which combination of good
touring and empirical frequency you can
find uh a distribution rp such that your
the distance the difference between the
l1 different distance between the
distribution
and your estimate is is matches the
upper bound that they had
one over n to the one sixth
um then you can ask whether there is a
you can find an estimator with better
performance something that will be
better than this and the answer is yes
you can derive an estimator such that uh
with high probability
the l1 distance is not going to go like
1 over n to the 1 6 but 1 over n to the
1 4.
so dividing by a larger number
and then you can ask whether this is
optimal
and the answer is yes
but this is also a lower bound
and
if you wanted to ask about kale
divergence then all these results will
hold
the square of these results will hold
for kale divergence it's one third one
half in one half
okay
so you can just look if you want just
look in the background
um
so basically you can improve on on
the good touring estimator and the way
to do it is um
the reason a good um good touring helps
you is because it reduces the the biases
we saw good touring
um was an unbiased estimator
but it has high
uh high variance so you look at the
difference between you look at the
difference between the um
the the the value and and what you and
what you estimate so the expected value
the bias is zero which is good but has
high variance and if you if you want to
reduce this result you need to come up
with an estimator that has both
uh low bias and low variance and that's
what these estimators
okay so a couple of observations so one
is that it holds for any k and it's
optimal and then uh you may ask like so
so if you looked at the kl divergent
side which was here then they got n to
the one-third and end to the one-half
you might say okay is it significant so
against we look we can look at a sample
complexity point of view which we
remember from last time kind of
accentuate things
so um so suppose that these constants
are the same but we it's not like we've
shown it but that's four seconds
so if you want to estimate things to
kill the version divergence which is
0.01
then um
good turing
and empirical the combination will
you'll want one over one over n to the
uh you'll have one over n to the one
third to be to be zero point zero one so
you need the million of these things
okay so uh whereas if you uh use our
approach
then you need it just to be 1 over delta
square so
100 square which is 10 000. so this
number is obviously
a lot easier to
obtain and also these things are
computationally efficient and
can be done in linear complexity
so um
and you can ask why do we care about
good touring so that's we'll talk about
tomorrow we will we'll talk about um
classification so you'll see that you
can use this to get results for
classification
so basically what we what we've said is
that um
here in this part is that um
if you
want to estimate the whole distribution
then you need the sample which is linear
in k but if you just want to estimate
the total probability of things that
appear at 0 1
and so on then you need a number of a
constant number of samples so you give
me the estimate like say i want to
estimate 2.01 i'll find this n
supplements and you'll be that close i
don't care what the distribution is
out of the double you can do that so
that's another approach a second
approach
i'll show you another example of this
approach in a second
uh where we kind of relaxed the question
that we asked and then the number of
samples went from
k
to just
anyone
a
constant
questions about this
there
yes
so what i want to do now is show you yet
another relaxation
um
so
so what we tried what we did now was we
estimated instead of estimating the the
the actual distribution we estimated the
combined probabilities cooperative
things appeared once twice and so on and
like i said one can argue that this is
the only thing you can do
if two things p if a and b appear the
same number of times the fact that they
have different probability is is a tree
that fell somewhere in the forest you'll
never be able to tell
you you've seen that they appeared the
same number of times
they the only thing you can do is just
give them the same the same probability
if you do that then if that's what
you're trying to do then you can
okay so what i want to do now is go a
step further and say not so so i'm not
just trying to estimate maybe the
probability of things that appeared once
twice and so on what i'm trying to do
now is just estimate um
the multi-set of probabilities to say
that the probabilities are 0.5.3.1
without associating them with the
individual elements
so i see a sequence of samples
i'm not trying to say what is the
probability of a what is probability of
b and so on i'm not trying to say what
is the probability of things that
appeared once or twice i'm just trying
to say give me the multiset of
probabilities
okay without caring about the
association
so um so the first question that we
could ask about this this this is
actually this result um
the results i'm going to describe now uh
were done earlier so these were krishna
vishwanathan and prasad santana and hira
kendu das um worked a lot on these
things and actually jai devi swelled on
later results and uh
so this is at the time where we a period
where we had more time to write keynote
slides
uh okay so um
so so um
okay so this is what we're trying to do
so the first question you ask is who
cares um like i'm i'm going to gamble on
a horse i want to know the probability
that this particular host wins this
particular host wins i don't care that
one host's probability 0.5 and one whole
is probably 0.3 without knowing
which horse has what probability right
so the first question to us is why
should we even care about this okay so
we'll be i'll give you a couple of
reasons to care
so um
so population estimation a lot of people
care about um the number of species in a
habitat okay so this will be the
cardinality of the set
so the cardinality of this side doesn't
depend on the association that just
depends on the set
so that's one the number of mutations
and so on
um
so for example sensors what happens is
that you you have a whole bunch of
sensors in the field and then you try to
estimate how many of them are alive so
you see each one comes to life each one
signals at some point
and then you have seen maybe
seven of them but you know that there
are more and you try to estimate what is
the the actual population there even
things that you've lost
um coverage so uh i've actually given
this talk and and the guy came up and he
said that uh he works for a a company
that designs uh drugs it's in the bay
area so you never know what kind of
drugs um but
but they're trying to um
they what they do is they they take some
compounds that they know are useful they
um mix them up and they get something
and at some point they'll start getting
repetitions
of the compounds so they'll get five
different uh molecules or something and
they'll get some some new molecule in
the test state and then we'll do it
again and they'll get a new one but at
some point they'll start getting many
repetitions and they want to know when
they've seen let's say 90 of the
different
combinations that they're ever going to
see that depends on just these
probabilities doesn't depend on what has
what
um
or robustness you're trying to design a
system like a wireless system for cell
phones uh that will accommodate people
ninety percent of the time ninety-nine
percent of the time all road that will
accommodate people 99 of the time you
don't so what you care about is what are
the probabilities that people use the
system at any given time i don't care
who has what probability just care about
the this there's a person who uses the
system 50 of the time another person 30
of the time and so on so just a function
of the multiset
okay and then also security maybe you
don't care about whom but you just want
to know what's the probability that you
see an unlikely event
or information theory we shouldn't even
be asking this question because we care
a lot about entropy it's just a function
of that
statistics that's all you care about so
so the answer to the question is who
cares the answer to the question who
cares is that everyone cares
um okay
so um so just to understand it's uh and
there'll be a little bit of repetition
here because of what we've discussed
last time so i'll go over this a little
quickly uh so so to say this so imagine
that um uh there's uh we've got visitors
and uh what we hear is this sequence of
uh symbols so at an pound and so on 60
ads and 40 pounds let's assume these
people are so unsophisticated that uh
that uh that these symbols are iid they
have no
structure
some of us
and um
and so if if if you analyze this
assuming independence then you'll say
how many how many symbols are in in
motion is
two very reasonable right uh and what
are the probabilities of the two symbols
notice we're not saying which we're just
saying they have two symbols one is
probability six one probably four
okay so so this this is the multiset
okay and what method did we use so we
use the method we described um
we described last time which is
empirical frequency right just use the
empirical frequency but we want to sound
a little more sophisticated today so we
call it maximum likelihood okay so what
is maximum likelihood um
so maximum likelihood is we're looking
for a distribution we observe some
sequence x and what we're looking is for
distribution that expect explain
explains what we have seen so we're
looking for distribution that will give
the highest probability to the sequence
we observed okay
so in this case we saw 60 ads and 40
pounds so we get the probability let's
say we call it p and then one minus p so
the probability of the sequence is p to
the sixty times one plus two to the 40.
and if you want to maximize we want to
find the p that will maximize this it
will give us
that p is 0.6 okay
so just maximize this
um and
so this says that um in this case if you
wanted to assign the values because the
probability of pound is 0.4 probability
of
we don't care about this we just care
that it probably is 0.6.4
so so
it's easy to show that maximum
likelihood always agrees with empirical
frequency so um always so for example we
see the 20 of one symbol 50 of 1 and 30
of the other then maximum likelihood try
to maximize the probability of p to the
20 times q to the 50 times r to the 30 p
plus q plus r1 give you 0.2.5.3
so um and we will always sort them so
we'll always write
so as we see it works well for a small
alphabet like here alphabet of size two
hundred samples worked well this is very
reasonable but as we're going to see now
it will look very poorly when the
alphabet is large
so to see that
let's assume we have not
different visitors and they speak not
more chinese but
they speak more chinese
so let's say
someone
sits here came from china and they write
a note and this is what the note says
anyone can explain
yeah
it's very boring
so um okay so so
reasonably likely reason because the
alphabet is sufficiently large if you
see 100 simples all of them will be
distinct that's very reasonable
uh assumption so um
um
so if you try to do maximum likelihood
on the sequence on this sequence then uh
what would you get the alphabet size to
be
100 right because we'll agree with
empirical frequency and each symbol will
have probability according to this will
be one percent right
uh one percent okay so um so this is
very clearly not working right it's a
very poor model because if i hear
someone speaks and and every symbol is
different
i'm not going to say if i heard them 100
i'm not going to say their vocabulary
size 100. okay so this this empirical
frequency breaks down here
and what would be a better uh what would
be a better assumption here a better
conclusion here i should say
the alphabet is
very large right maybe infinite because
if the alphabet was infinite then it
would explain why every symbol was
different
okay so it's very explicit so large
maybe infinite alphabet
all right so let's do a thought
experiment and say
that
we're not looking at the probability of
each of those symbols which i don't know
i don't know almost none of these
symbols so i'm not looking for the
probability here
what i care about is the multiset of
probabilities
okay so so i don't care about the values
so what if
we can do is consider what we call the
pattern
um and so um
so so the pattern will say
uh we'll just replace those by numbers
okay so
um ignore this so what is the pattern so
so the pattern is the first symbol i say
call it one and then two and so on so
this in this case the pattern is going
to be one up to 100. is that clear so
the first symbol c is one and then the
second one two and so on if i saw aba
the pattern would be one to one
but here so abc the pattern is one two
three up to one hundred
and that just signifies that all of them
are different
so
so
so now i can ask this is my pattern
sufficient statistic for me for what i
want which is just the collection of the
multiset not the probability of each one
what will which distribution will
maximize the probability that if i take
a hundred samples
the pattern will be 1 up to 100 namely
all of them will be different
the answer is exactly this it's exactly
that a large
and possibly infinite alphabet will
maximize the probability that
all of them will be different in other
words the pattern will be one up to 100.
you want to agree with that
yes yes okay all right so so what we
want to do is we want to
to compare um
to compare the performance of
this pattern maximum likelihood to
sequence maximum likelihood
okay so um so um
so we see that it's better for very
large alphabet like here alphabet is
let's you can think of as infinity
but how does it
perform for small alphabets
so um
how much more time do you have
nothing
no choice profit perfect okay
question withdrawn your chair no okay
good
yeah
okay i
thank you nominated self nominated okay
so um
so i just want to because in order to
explain what we do uh and the results we
get i need to
to show you how to do it so um
so
um
as always we assume the sequence is
independent identically distributed
always and it will induce the
probability on the pattern so if we
denote the pattern for example one to
one
then uh the probability of this pattern
is the probability of observing this
pattern it's the probability of all
outcomes with this pattern okay so we'll
do an example so for example the
alphabet is abc and equal probability
uniform so if we have one sample the
pattern is going to be one right because
the first symbol we call one so what is
the probability that we'll get one if i
take one sample i'll get this this
bubble is going to be one
okay one sample the pattern is going to
be one if i take two samples what are
the possible patterns it could be one
one meaning they have so the same piece
symbols twice or it could be one two i
saw different two different symbols so
it's one one one two what is the
probability of one one it's the
probability that i get one of these
three sequences
and you can see this a is probably one
ninth and so on so this probability is
going to be one third okay and this just
means that probability second is the
same as the first
what's the probability of one two it's a
probability of all these sequences and
and we already know it has to be
two-thirds because these are the only
two patterns so it's going to be
two-thirds okay it's the probability the
second is not equal to the first okay so
this just explains two people don't know
what the pattern is what it is
um okay so
that's you can see the patterns are no
longer distributed to the id because
probably of one one is now the
probability of one square
um
okay so um
so what we want to do is we want to do
the maximum likelihood that we did
before and on the sequence we want to do
it on the pattern
so given a pattern for one for example
one two one three we want to find the
highest probability p hat uh the highest
probability that this pattern can get
and the distribution that achieves this
and that's it okay so let's look at
length one there's only um one pattern
one and what is the highest probability
it can get it's clearly
one
um and which achieved by white save by
any distribution we'll give it that okay
is everyone understand what we mean by
pattern
yeah
let's look at length two um and then now
we have one one and one two what is the
hash probability that one one can get
one
and it's achieved by what what type of
distribution
constant thank you
um and how about one two what is the
hash probability that one two can get
one
and achieve y
any form of infinite
so notice so by large distributions yeah
so notice some people might say quarter
but they're thinking of of coins we're
not limiting ourselves to alphabet of
size two so we're looking at any
alphabet
okay
it's not really yet is it pretty
yeah it approaches one so uh defined
test the ice the limit
yeah
if you allow yourself yeah
okay
so actually the way we
do it is we allow us of some continuous
distributions
yeah but just look at the limit don't
worry length three the probability of
one one one the highest probability is
one the highest probability of one two
three is again one the same
so the first interesting one is one one
two
and um
um and so and that has the same
probabilities one two one and one two
two because it's iid
this this means that you have the same
the same element period first two
location and different in the third
location and so on so we have the same
question is what maximizes it okay
so
so so um
so this is equivalent to flipping three
coins and getting headsets tails for
example okay so this gives you the
pattern so if that happens sequence
maximum might so more likely to tell you
what are the probabilities
sequence maxima not the original will
tell you you've seen one one thing you
have to see twice the other one once
you'll say probability maximum
likelihood is two thirds third
and
the question is what does pattern
maximize likelihood give you here
and the hope is
the hope is
that um
we saw that maximum likelihood works
better for infinite alphabets
in chinese this is the smallest possible
alphabet size two heads and tails
um if it also works better here for this
example
unlikely but if it worked better here
then there is some chance it works
better in between okay okay so let's
calculate the highest probability that
one went to that we show it's a quarter
so we showed it
it's at least a quarter and then we show
that it's at most a quarter okay so the
shortest explicit quarter we need to
give a distribution so suppose you're
flipping a fair coin headset entirely
half what is the probability that you
see one one two probability of headsets
tails or tails this heads each of them
is probability one eighth
and this one
so there is a distribution namely a fair
coin that will give this pattern one one
two four will t one quarter
right flip a coin the probability that i
see one one two is one
now the question is whether there is
another distribution that will give one
one two a probability which is bigger
than a quarter maybe half
and should be of a binary alphabet
ternary alphabet in the alphabet so we
showed that no and this is fairly easy
so the probability of one one two you
have to submit sum of all possible x's
of
what this is of the probability that x
appeared twice and then something
different appears
so p square of x times one minus p x
okay so now once you look at it for a
little bit you can see that you can
shuffle things a little bit and write p
x and then p x times one minus x
when you have this it's at most a
quarter p times one minus p
so it's summation px ten squares
so you cannot get any higher
which distribution achieves it because
we want to find the distribution that
achieves it to achieve it you need to
get equality here so you need p of x uh
times one minus p of x to be a quarter
for every x
so you you need p of x to be half for
every x so it's the distribution of the
two other elements so it's 0.5.5
so um so so what we see is that for
headsets tails sequence maximum
likelihood tells you two-thirds
one-third
okay pattern maximum like tells you
half-half and the question is which
makes more sense
okay and again if we if we
um if if we convince ourselves that
0.5.5 that is more logical here than
we've shown it's more logical in the
whole range so we have some hope
okay so um sorry
so um okay so which is more logical
so remember that we are not looking for
the public of heads and public hotels
that's that was yesterday
and now we're looking at just the
probability multiset p and one minus p
that's all we care about okay
so um i'll give you two reasons why
um
why we believe that half half maximal is
more logical
uh so the first reason
is that we flip the coin three times
okay so if i flip the coin four times
and i get two heads and two tails fine
half half but i flip the coin three
times i cannot expect one and a half
heads
and one and a half tails so i'll never
say half of
so so this is impossible and what we saw
is two and one which is the closest to
this okay
so that's one reason why
we believe this is more possible more
reasonable the second reason
is that what are the possible outcome
when you flip three coins
either one side will appear three times
for example heads its head or tells us
this or one side will appear twice and
one side will appear once okay
now what we saw in this case of one one
two um
two what we saw is this this is what we
saw this is what we didn't see okay
what will explain better explain what we
have seen
if you take a distribution that we we
believe half of is is the reasonable
explanation if you take anything that is
different from from uniform
for example two-thirds one-third then
that will make this more likely it will
make the will make it will increase the
probability of the same thing if you
take two thirds one third it will
increase the probability of one sided
three times which is what we have not
seen
it will decrease the probability of uh
one thing appearing twice in one thing
period which was what you have seen okay
so anything else will decrease the
probability of what you
have seen will increase probably of what
you have not seen yes
so it seems that all this argument is
based upon that you don't care about the
meaning of heads and things right so
once they actually mean something you
might refer to the absolutely absolutely
yeah yeah right so remember that uh what
we're doing today is we're changing the
problem a little bit
to get results that are
to get around the problem that you need
a lot of samples so it's seeing what
problems can can you do with fewer than
linear number of samples
but you're right if uh we're not saying
this you only will do it if you don't
care about the values and i gave you a
few reasons why you might not care about
which switches are right like coverage
and so on if you care about the
individual values that's not what you
want
okay so so this second thing also shows
that half half is more logical
so
so we see that for large alphabets
pattern maximum a lot more logical for
binary alphabet more logical in between
i'll show you in
at most 10 minutes it's more logical
and um so what we have seen is that
we've calculated the probability maximum
likelihood of all these things which was
very easy
right so uh and if it's too easy uh then
you can ask what is the highest
probability of one one two okay
and i'm sure people here could do it but
i just have to warn you a little bit
that this
this problem appeared not in this name
but in a different you know like the
same formulation appeared in what's
considered to be the the hardest uh
international math olympiad ever
but let me we don't have even though we
don't have um
a session here i should not abuse this
let me let me let me skip a few slides
so this was going to show you what the
problem that they had and what's the
connection
um
okay so just give you a summary of the
results that you can get um
so um
so you can show that pattern maximum
likelihood always is a smooth version of
sequence maximum likelihood which is
kind of nicer because when you estimate
distribution you want to smooth things
typically and you can show
an infinity convergence you can also
show l1 convergence i didn't write it
here but what you can show is that
what you can show is that
if
if you want to estimate
the probability multiset
of
k elements
then roughly you need k over log k
samples so you can reduce it from k to k
over log k so you can do that and now i
didn't write but i'll show you some some
results that you can get and i should
say that um
greg and paul valiant have a method
that's very closely related to this so
our maximum likelihood our pattern
maximum likelihood is we we look at this
we're trying to we observe a pattern and
we're trying to find a distribution that
will um maximize the probability of this
and
what so this is our
our definition of explains this maximize
the probability and they subsequently
came up with some um with a related
method where they look at the
distribution that will whose expected
value is what of the number of times
everything appears is what you have seen
and that also has the same
singular very similar performance
um okay so um
so you can
i'm going to skip this but you can you
have a whole bunch of results if i give
you a specific sequence what will the
pattern
what will the pattern maximize look like
and so on
uh i just want to show you some
experiments
so here's the uniform distribution of
500 symbols and we're taking 350 samples
so
we'll never be able to estimate the
whole distribution because we'll never
see all of those
so in this particular run
the two elements appeared six times and
three elements appeared four times and
so on uh 161 elements appeared once if
you sum the numbers that you see that
there are 242 things that appeared
right so 161.1 plus 63 elements plus 13.
so 242 symbols appear
out of that mostly could have you could
have had uh 350 and that means that more
than half of the 500 did not appear
okay so if you did sequence maximum
likelihood you'll get this thing so
you'll get these are the things that six
times and
four times and so on uh up to the things
that appeared once and you get that more
than half you have not seen at all so
you're missing a couple things
you're missing big time the support size
uh you're missing also the fact that
it's uniform
on the other hand if you apply if you
look and try and maximize the
probability of what you've seen here
then you'll get this
so you get close to the number of um
close to the number of samples quite
close and you get the uniformity you get
here is spike and that's because in this
particular example the things appear six
times four times so something funny
happened there's no this five did not
appear so it thinks that there's
something that has higher property
if you repeat this experiment
12 times you get all these
these things so you see sometimes very
good sometimes
is not so good but always of course
better than
um
what i showed you was i think this one
the
sixth lesson
if instead of uh if instead of 350 times
you double the number of
samples maybe almost
750
then
the same distribution
then if you do sequence maximum
likelihood you'll get this so
get more samples but still you miss a
lot and still i think it's not uniform
but if you use pattern maximum
likelihood you get this if you repeat it
12 times
almost always the same okay and you know
all these things are monotone because we
just care about the the multiset so we
always just draw it monotone just sorted
um
and then you can do it for other things
as well
so
then
um
you so again sorry um
you can use it
um second
you can use it for to estimate uh
population so so like we said one one
application of this is to estimate the
population of um
things that you observe
and
there are um
this particularly has been applied to um
to estimate a shakespearean vocabulary
this is uh f1b said and
they tried to estimate his vocabulary um
in this particular case they
were
they found a song a poem that uh people
thought was distributed to shakespeare
and and uh
it had so many
words and so many were new and they were
trying to see what if shakespeare wrote
it what
shakespeare wrote another a song of that
length 430 words how many new words will
appear
and they calculated that it should be
about seven and
one
so if you
apply our approach then you you take
shakespeare's um
things that he wrote
and then you try to see once you do that
you get distribution and then you can
try to estimate what's the probability
of how many
new words you'll expect of if you had
430 new things and and you'll see that
you get the result it's very close to
that okay
and um
and um
i'm showing you a little too much
um
and you can
do this
so um
so so you can apply this to estimating
um
number of new symbols so as if
distribution over 15 000 symbols and you
sample 30 000 times and you want to
estimate
the number of new symbols you'll see if
you take this is how many are sampled
and you take lambda times that and how
many new symbols you'll see
so if you use um
a method by good and truman which is
what f1 and this they've used then for
lambda which is less than one so we took
if you have if you some point is of size
30 000
and you say okay i'm going to take 15
000
things how many things will appear it
actually will be very accurate
but
when you go beyond 30 000 if you say i'm
going to take now 31 000 new things then
it diverges
okay and um
on the other hand if you use
this pattern maximum likelihood and then
predict then it behaves
much more massive
okay so it extends for estimating
properties beyond one
uh and
then it can apply to other predictions
not just number of elements
this is one sample and this is uh
five
samples so you can see in many of them
it
behaves fairly well not always like here
for example it's still better than
the bounds that they would get
so i think
maybe i'll stop here um but what i want
to
to say today
is that
sometimes you don't need to estimate all
the individual
probabilities of every element and then
you can reduce it
from a linear number of samples to below
that like in the case of combined
probabilities to actually a constant
in this case to k over log k but also
get some results that work
nicely
for large alphabets and
tomorrow what we're going to do is we're
going to use some of these results to um
to get some competitive behavior to so
show that you can use this to to
do things essentially as well as anyone
else
any questions
yeah so this is a high level question so
if you think about a probability
distribution which you know the
structure is that the first thing is the
most likely the monotone case it seems
that the pattern is almost like you get
a multiset right so this is like the
most probable element there's not some
highest probability some next highest
probabilities and next times
probabilities one might be equal
but if you
like is there any kind of consistency
between what your predict what your
results are for monotone and what they
are for pattern
so um
of course it depends on how
you know how steep the monotone is
if you're using um
reasonable um reasonable um distribution
like zif distribution then even though
your probabilities go monotone they will
not appear monotonically
just think
that you have um you know like you have
let's say 1 over i and now i is uh you
know
200 so the difference between 1 over 200
1 over 201 is very small so things
actually will not be monotone
so um
so therefore um
um
what you
if if what you are saying is that you're
trying to come up with uh things
so so um
so you cannot expect i realize i'm not
answering exactly your question but you
can definitely not expect that the
monotone that what you see will observe
the monotone order of what you do now
what we described yesterday was still
supposed to work because it's assumed
that the distribution is monotone
uh but
what we're saying is that it could be a
strong assumption right because who
knows that things are monitoring or not
but um so um
so in this case you'll you'll get
something and then you'll sort it i'm
not sure because what you'll get is is
not it does not obey this the order and
then you sort it it's kind of funny so
i'm not
sure i guess that's the bottom line of
my answer
you had a choice right someone said okay
you have a choice you could either try
either i will give you a monotone
distribution and you have to estimate it
or
i will give you you said like the
the multi-set probability multiset
which problem would you choose
that's a very good question um
which is more informative or what's like
i guess one is informed about the
distribution and the others making the
problem easier i think i think i think i
it seems to me like if you know that the
distribution is monotone
that then doing what they do makes a lot
more assumptions than we do here
so we say you give me any distribution
we'll take it and then we sort it we
made no assumption on the distribution
we just sorted it if you know that the
distribution is monotone and and the
element a has higher probability than b
higher probability in c
you
must use it i mean if you don't use this
and we don't use it you must be losing
some information so i don't have a proof
that in that case they'll work better
but because there's
assuming so much structure they must be
gaining something out of it
and this is the case what would they
would
probably it's not like i know a proof of
it
this this sorting is just like an
artifact of like us trying to show you
things in a nice way
yes yes so
your pattern so how efficient we can
compute the whole business is maximize
this
that's a good that's a very good
question
um so um
we don't know i mean like we don't know
if an efficient way of doing it
um
what um
we do is we use an em algorithm so uh we
take up some we take some some
distribution and then we try to find a
distribution that will get closer and
closer and closer and that's the
approach that we use to get things like
for like to get these results
okay
um so
we actually don't know that this
always works so while we know that the
pml that the actual distribution will
give you the results they said you can
you can estimate with k over lock a the
algorithms that we have now we don't
have a guarantee for them if you look at
paul and greg variant then the alvin the
performance is similar but
for their for their problem they can
actually have an algorithm that will
achieve it so that's the difference
so do you know for example if you if you
have enough samples so let's say you're
close enough in some sense there's a
distribution that you do conversate
i don't know that that's the case
building on that is it do you know if
the maximization problem you are solving
is and behind
um no i don't know um so you're trying
to maximize remind you something over a
continuous space
so it's not the discrete we have p1 p2
does that take place in rn and you're
trying to actually just approximate you
know you never try to actually even for
them they're not trying to achieve it
you try to approximate to get within
some someone give you some
you know like
delta that you want to be within
so it's maybe a little bit different but
is it always maximizing a polynomial
yes it's always maximizing a symmetric
polynomial
yeah and in fact um in fact um
this is a very interesting problem for
us which if you solve you then you'll
help us solve the actually the
algorithmic thing whether so this is so
the polynomial for example for one one
two is summation of uh uh so it's going
to be if you have two elements so it's
uh p square q plus q square p it's
always a symmetric point we always look
at all possible mutations always like
that and it's always a single orbit as
they call it so it's just like
p p1 to the 5 p2 to the 3 p3 to the one
and then just just a single element just
take all permutations this is what we're
doing and one question is whether it has
a unique maximum this this maximization
look at all the p's
so and i'll look at p one bigger than p
two bigger than or equal to p two p
three if there's a unique maximum if
there's unique maximum then of course we
can say a lot about already but we don't
know that
so if
that had an answer then i think it would
help us a lot in getting the same topic
so experimentally it seems to work fine
works well this this algorithm all this
stuff that i showed is using this
algorithm but to prove it something like
that would help us
you